blue ivy carter is celebrating double
digits
yep it's b day beyonce and jay-z's
daughter blue ivy's b day that is what's
the best thing about being a mom so far
it's just i have such a full life i feel
like now i know the reason why i was
born b and j's little girl turns 10 on
friday and her grandma tina knowles
lawson is celebrating the occasion on
instagram posting this sweet snap
standing side by side on the beach and
yeah blue is almost as tall as tina i'm
just so excited that's miss tina rocking
a polka dot jumpsuit while blue looks
all grown up in a black blazer over a
white ensemble complete with shades
it's a beautiful really beautiful tina
captions the post in part quote my
beautiful talented and super smart
granddaughter blue ivy turned 10 today
god it seemed like yesterday you came
into the world running things
b's mom who turned 68 on january 4th
continues her post calling blue her
quote little capricorn twin quote i
prayed for her to be born on my birthday
but she did what she always does she
came when she got good and ready three
days later but we still share the bond
pretty cute right well it gets even
cuter quote blue gives the best advice
like a grown person i sometimes forget
that she is so young blue is one of
those rare gifted people that can do
everything well god blessed me the day
you were born it's exciting you know
it's a wonderful experience
celeb pals like gabrielle union naomi
campbell and adrian houghton all left
their love in the comments i'm very
happy and while blue may only be 10 her
resume is already stacked last year she
won her first grammy taking home the
trophy for best music video for
beyonce's track brown skin girl
[Music]
not only did she star in the music video
the track features her vocals and she
even wrote a verse
[Music]
singing i mean i can't get enough of it
of course i'm not biased
but uh yeah that was wonderful and for
blue to be a part of it it's amazing the
youngster's voice is also featured on
the audiobook for hair love which is
based off matthew a cherry's
oscar-winning short film dreamscape
presents hair love
by matthew a cherry
narrated by blue ivy carter what went
into you choosing miss blue ivy carter
to be the voice of the book
um you know just being aware of kind of
all the flack that you know yeah and
jay-z got for you know styling her hair
natural when she was a kid
i had the pleasure of uh
you know meeting them so i reached out
and you know to our surprise you know
they were down and if all that wasn't
impressive enough little blue has also
starred in a bunch of campaigns
yeah
really chic and fabulous campaigns
[Music]
back in october blue made a cameo with
her famous parents in a video
celebrating tiffany and company
[Music]
and a month later she and her little sis
roomie posted up for their famous mom's
latest ivy park collection
[Music]
and all that creativity is echoed by
what tina told et back in 2019 about
blue having a real talent for makeup and
she's quite a makeup artist is she yeah
she's amazing
what is like her specialty
eyes oh my gosh she puts stones and does
all this fancy stuff she can do a
perfect cat eye oh she'd be perfect
right here
and for tina it's all about family when
eti caught up with her in may she said
the best part about quarantining amid
the pandemic was getting more quality
time with her crew the best thing of
course was being with my grandchildren
almost every day and
and
i think it made us appreciate each other
seeing friends and seeing family you you
realize what was important you know so i
think a lot of good came from it happy
10th birthday blue
[Music]
you